et nos invités christian saint-etienne
économiste et jean guilhem darré délégué
général du syndicat des indépendants et
des tpe les très petites entreprises
bonsoir messieurs merci de répondre à
nos questions sur arte france une pme
sur deux craint donc je le disais de ne
pas pouvoir supporter un troisième
confinant alexis blanc l'a rappelé
également tout à l'heure c'est une étude
une enquête de la ceppm la confédération
des petites et moyennes entreprises qui
a interrogé 2400 dirigeants regardez sur
ces chiffres dont 49 pour cent des chefs
d'entreprise estiment ne pas être en
capacité de supporter un troisième
confinement 33% des chefs d'entreprise
ont le sentiment que leur entreprise est
sous perfusion de l'état ces chiffres
messieurs ils font froid dans le dos la
mise en place d'un troisième confinement
ce serait quoi ce serait un coup de
grâce à jean guilhem darré
nous nous avons réalisé une enquête nous
mêmes à auprès des nouveaux prêts des
pme mais auprès des tpe des artisans des
commerçants des entreprises de moins de
10 salariés et les chiffres sont en
ligne on constate effectivement que 71 %
de ces entreprises ont connu une baisse
de chiffre d'affaires sur un an dès 2020
et que pour 51% à ce jour elle rencontre
des difficultés de trésorerie soit
importante soit jusqu'à catastrophique
alors forcément dans ce contexte là avec
en plus un confinement qui pourrait
arriver dans les prochains jours
la situation pourrait pour un grand
nombre d'entre elles a mené à une
impossibilité de rebond on a clairement
pour celles qui ont utilisé qui ont
utilisé le pg e on en a à peu près 40%
qu'ils ont déjà consommé quasiment dans
son intégralité et surtout dans la très
grande majorité des cas 90% des cas
c'était pour payer des charges des
charges courantes
les tpe donc les très petites
entreprises elles représentent 95% des
entreprises françaises qu'est ce que ça
signifie qu'elles jouent leur survie de
cette manière là avec cette pièce du coc
vie de christian saint-etienne alors
c'est 95 % en nombre mais en chiffres
d'affaires ont valeur ajoutée surtout
c'est un de l'ordre du tiers dépend ce
qu'on entend par dix ans les pme de
moins de 50 personnes
donc c'était vite
effectivement décisif pour l'emploi sur
les territoires c'est décisif pour
l'emploi dans le dans le commerce
ce que l'on observe c'est que comme les
chiffres qui viennent d'être donnés le
confirme l'année 2020 a vu une baisse de
l'activité de 9% mais c'est pas 9% pour
tout le monde
vous avez entre 15 et 20 % de l'économie
en équivalent ping qui a augmenté son
activité et qui va accélérer en 2021
vous avez 60 65 % qui a baissé de 9%
comme l'économie et vous avez 15 % qui
va être totalement restructurée on
estime qu'il va falloir former et
reformer un million et demi de personnes
sur 18 mois 2 ans on ne voit pas l'état
se prépare et d'ailleurs à cet effort là
donc dans ce contexte d'extrême
fragilité où on estime qu'il y a au
niveau de l'économie française 12 ou 13%
ce qu'on appelle les entreprises zombies
c'est à dire les entreprises qui n'ont
pas n'ont même pas le profit nécessaires
pour payer les intérêts sur leur
endettement
donc non ce contexte d'extrême fragilité
rajouter un nouveau confinement
tout dépend de la nature du confinement
d'ailleurs rajouté un nouveau
confinement disons strictes comme celui
du printemps 2020 serait serait une
vraie catastrophe
d'autant plus que
sur ce qui reste encore avec la tête au
dessus du niveau de la mer c'est ce sont
les entreprises qui sont défendues et
soutenue par la dette publique mais
c'est uniquement les autres les autres
comment comment elles peuvent faire
genre jean guilhem darré
pour se relever comment fais-tu combien
vont rester sur le carreau également
alors nous on a évalué à environ 300
milles le nombre de tpe qui pourrait
disparaître d'ici la fin de l'année soit
qu'elles n'auront pas la possibilité de
rembourser leurs pge soit que tu ne rend
pas la possibilité de payer leurs dettes
parce que tout naturellement n'ont pas
eu ou n'ont pas obtenu le pge il ya pas
36 façons en fait 1,2 de se remettre
soit l'activité reprend mais bon a
priori on n'est pas parti pour sur les
prochains mois
le président de la république ailleurs
elle a indiqué tout à l'heure donc si la
seule solution finalement c'est
s'étendit âgées une une annulation
clairement une annulation des charges
que ce soit les charges sociales les
charges fiscales et pourquoi pas aussi
une annulation pour les entreprises qui
ont la possibilité de rebondir
une annulation du pge alors certes ça va
entre guillemets coûter de l'argent on
en est bien conscient maintenant ce
qu'il faut voir c'est que si on regarde
au niveau européen la france a encore
des marges de manoeuvre par rapport à
nos voisins allemands ou nos voisins
anglais compte tenu du fait que le
niveau des 1 z qui a été qu'ils ont été
accordés jusqu'à présent et je parle
naturellement des tpe est nettement
moins en france on a en a mis sur la
table 25 milliards d'euros en allemagne
c'était 81 milliards en angleterre
c'était c'était 50 milliards donc il ya
quand même des possibilités qui existent
à pays comparables économies comparables
de soutenir encore nos entreprises
celles au minimum qui qui ont la
possibilité de rebondir mais pas dans
les conditions dans lesquelles nous on
est avec un mur de dette insurmontable
je n'ai qu'à le gouvernement compte
tenir sa stratégie du quoi qu'il en
coûte 1 je vous propose de voir ce qu'a
dit tout à l'heure
elisabeth bornes la mise
tant que la crise le rendra nécessaire
on protégera les emplois avec l'activité
partielle temps qu'il faudra aussi
longtemps que nécessaire
la priorité est de sauver le maximum
d'emplois il n'y a aucun doute le quoi
qu'il en coûte durera aussi longtemps
que la crise le nécessitera donc quoi
qu'il en coûte donc avec le chômage
partiel ça sauf les emplois mais est-ce
que c'est pas plutôt une mise sous
cloche qui empêche les entreprises de
déposer le bilan à ce que c'est pas au
final reculer pour mieux sauter
christian saint-etienne il ya un tiers
des entreprises qui sont en difficulté
qui de toute façon vont disparaître
parce qu'elle était déjà pour la plupart
en difficulté avant le confinement toute
la question c'est ce que je disais tout
à l'heure c'est de reformer les
travailleurs pour qu'on puisse les
déplacer vers les activités qui vont
redémarrer à partir du mois de mai juin
faut pas non plus désespérée on a encore
trois mois difficiles mais il ya une
corrélation très forte entre le froid et
l'humidité et d'une part et la pandémie
donc à partir de d'avril
il va y avoir une très forte
amélioration par ailleurs on a une
vaccination qui produira des effets
d'ici avril sur l'épais personnes
faibles donc on va se retrouver avec une
situation où à partir de mai juin on va
avoir un certain rebond alors vous avez
raison
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure on
va aider les entreprises
vraisemblablement jusqu'au milieu de
l'année à travers le chômage partiel
mais à partir de la deuxième moitié de
l'année ce qu'il va falloir faire c'est
faire le tri entre les entreprises qui
peuvent survivre
celle là effectivement il n'y aura pas
d'annulations d'être personne peut
annuler de la tête parce que s'il ya une
contrepartie est la contrepartie que
c'est quelqu'un qui paye ça sera
toujours le contribuable donc c'est une
nouvelle augmentation de de
l'endettement public ce qui aura
probablement est-ce que le gouvernement
qui commence à essayer de faire mais
qu'il ne fait pas avec lenteur
nécessaire c'est d aide en fonds propres
le gouvernement travaille sur des aides
en quasi fonds propres il est en
négociation avec la commission
européenne à hauteur de 20 milliards
d'euros mais c'est très insuffisant il
va falloir compléter cette initiative
de quasi fonds propres par une
initiative de fonds propres de l'ordre
de 70 milliards d'euros j'ai publié des
propositions il ya certains groupes qui
réfléchissent sur cette initiative là et
ça sera pas pour aider les entreprises
qui vendent mal ça sera pour aider les
entreprises qui sont encore viable
c'est-à-dire les entreprises qui
n'étaient pas en perte avant la pandémie
et qui avait encore des fonds propres
positifs à la fin 2020 donc il va y
avoir l'année 2021 va être une année de
très forte restructuration de l'appareil
de production avant ça va être une année
désagréable et difficile
tout le monde ne sera pas aider et
sauver mais il faut faire en sorte que
le potentiel de redéveloppement et de
redéploiement de l'économie française
soit reconstruit pour que on est des
années correct en 22 et 23 par les
années 2022 2023 je propose un petit
flashback en 2010 est parce qu un
chiffre qui inquiète les économistes
dont vous faites partie celui de la
dette
98 5% du produit intérieur brut en 2010
est tout bonnement l'élection d'
emmanuel macron plus de 122 % cette
année à cause des mesures prises pour
relancer l'économie à la suite donc de
la crise du call it qui va payer
jean-guilhem darré
pour l'instant on a la possibilité
encore d'emprunter la france emprunte à
des taux extrêmement intéressant bono le
maire a indiqué qu'il pourrait y avoir
des possibilités de cantonner la dette
qu'ovide donc dans l'absolu on n'est pas
très inquiet sur l'avenir
nous ce qui nous inquiète ce sont nos
entreprises et c'est assez symptomatique
d'ailleurs ce que vous indiquiez par
rapport à madame bornes on parle de
soutien aux salariés
quand on parle de soutien de l'emploi on
parle de soutien aux salariés mais pour
qu'il y ait des salariés pour qu'il y
ait de l'emploi il faut qu'ils aient des
entreprises sinon on va pas s'en sortir
les fonds propres les quasi-fonds
propres
tout ça c'est intéressant ce sont des
éléments qui peuvent être mis sur la
table mais ça va ça va durer pendant 7
ans pendant 10 ans et ça reste quand
même une somme qui va être à rembourser
donc il faut bien concevoir que dans
l'esprit du chef d'entreprise bossé
pendant 7 ans pendant 10 ans pour
rembourser une dette dont il n'est pas
responsable en aucune en aucune façon et
qui lui aura servi à payer des charges
courantes c'est c'est totalement
abérrant donc la possibilité on n'est
pas les seuls à le dire certains
économistes le disent aussi la
possibilité d'annuler les dettes
totalement partiellement on peut voir
effectivement selon l'état de la
structure est une possibilité à
envisager très sérieusement
dernière question le mot de la fin
christian saint-etienne le medef qui a
appelé à maintenir les commerces ouverts
en cas de confinement et puis le médecin
je re martyrs de l'union française pour
une médecine ligne qui propose lui
d'ouvrir les petits commerces et de
fermer les grandes surfaces cette
fois-ci bonne idée je parle évidemment à
l'économiste 1 que vous êtes non il faut
laisser l'ensemble des commerces et des
artisans ou r c'est pas eux qui sont à
l'origine de la dissémination du coc
vide
il faut regarder on le sait ça fait ça
fait plus de six mois qu'on le sait
c'est dans la sphère privée que le coc
vide circule le plus et surtout dans les
fêtes privées conte dont on a eu
connaissance dans les derniers mois
donc c'est pas en accusant le commerce
et les artisans qu'on progresse
l'économiste encore vivant si on ferme
l'économie tout meurt donc ça a été la
grande erreur au printemps de fermer
beaucoup pris longtemps que les
autrichiens les allemands nous avons
réouvert
11 mai ils ont rêvé rire quinze jours
plus tôt il faut savoir que une semaine
complète de fermeture ça coûte 0,8 à 0,9
point de pub une vingtaine de milliards
par semaine donc fermé c'est une
stupidité absolue ce qui est en revanche
nécessaire c'est de fermer les
frontières éventuellement de limiter les
transports de région à région
donc plutôt que de fermer mais ces
mesures de bon sens le gouvernement n'a
pas voulu les mettre en oeuvre pour des
raisons idéologiques
il y vient tardivement en exigent
maintenant mais seulement maintenant
alors que ça fait quasiment un an quand
des dans cette pandémie des tests pcr
pour les gens qui viennent des autres
pays européens
mais quand vous regardez je termine par
là les pays qui s'en sont bien sortis
comme taïwan et la corée du sud
ils ont totalement fermé leurs
frontières et très vite c'est comme ça
qu'ils s'en sont sortis donc bouclé les
français en laissant les frontières
ouvertes c'est une aberration absolue
donc il faut fermer les frontières faut
contrôler les mouvements de population à
l'intérieur du territoire
peut-être en limitant les transferts de
région à région
mais fermer les commerces et les
artisans en laissant les frontières
ouvertes c'est une aberration absolue
merci christian saint-etienne d'avoir
répondu à la question je rappelle que
vous êtes économiste merci également à
vous jean guilhem darré d'avoir
également répondu à nos questions et
vous êtes le délégué général du syndicat
indépendant des tpe